one year you're going to chest box
against Eric Rosen this is a question
from Reddit chessbox you uh you said
your your hands are all messed up
yeah yeah are you training for something
or regular like so I also just
remembered we never talked about Hikaru
so I can talk about Rosen and Hikaru in
the same chess boxing oh [ __ ] is this
your McGregor like
[ __ ] talk segment no no no no no uh Eric
Rosen is actually a close friend of mine
I probably have five of those and he
just so happens to be
uh not just the chess streamer but I we
we talked about buying homes we've
talked about he's stayed at my place he
took my wedding photos
I flew him to New York and paid for all
his stuff just so he could hang out with
my wife and I and you know take some 6
a.m photos in the sun uh in in the park
so oh he looks familiar yeah
so he's uh yeah he's a good friend of
mine now in terms of Chess boxing
sales boxing is this really fascinating
sport where you have boxing but you also
have chess and you have rounds
so you start a chess game with a clock
that segment itself lasts for a couple
of minutes they put the board away and
pause the clock whatever the time
situation is then you box for a minute
and that keeps going on I don't know how
it works in terms of the time expiring
meaning in fighting there's judges that
just tell you how the fight was going
right here I don't know who wins and how
like do you win by you can win by
knockout you can win by Checkmate or
their clock can run out on the
chessboard but it's the judges who is
there a round limit does this just go on
and on and on and on you know what I
mean yeah I thought it's like 12 rounds
right isn't this a thing in in Russia
it's a big thing in the UK UK yeah UK I
don't I don't know why and there's a lot
of YouTuber events just for boxing so
YouTubers just learn to box and then
they just box no chess they just
straight up box each other like Jake
Paul for example you ever gonna get Jake
Paul in here yeah yeah I'm sure okay I'm
sure I feel like we're just so many
different guests have been mentioned uh
Jake but Jake Paul would be it would be
a fun guess but he's obviously the
biggest scouter he's legitimately boxing
people he's not yeah uh but okay chess
players is never going to learn the box
to that level and all of us are starting
basically from zero and Ludwig talked to
me behind the scenes say hey how would
you feel about being in a chess boxing
match
I said okay yeah maybe when is it going
to be he said five months from now I've
always wanted to train combat I've
weight lifted I've done cardio I've
played here UFC fan too yeah but do you
admire fighting yeah I would enjoy it I
just have a really bad lower back
and that makes a lot of different combat
difficult
but I said you know what screw this I'm
going to contact a few local gyms yeah
and one of them the guy emailing me back
and forth had actually watched my
YouTube videos
so he was the first to respond and he
said yeah like come in do a couple
classes like see how you feel so first I
did conditioning which killed me because
fighting conditioning as you know it
kills you it's a completely different
type of conditioning but I felt good and
I really wanted to come back and since
July I've been training three four days
a week nice yeah I feel pretty good I
love it lower back feels good lower
everything the whole body got stronger
so what you're saying is you're gonna
[ __ ] up Hikaru it's easy training I'm
not I'm not fighting so I talked to Eric
about it and the truth is we're both
concerned about head trauma I haven't
actually sparred I like sparring Shadow
Boxing but I go there I do personal
training I don't do
a group class I'm not fighting I'm
fighting the bag I'm doing Shadow Boxing
my form is improving but I haven't been
punched I get hit in the stomach you
know I get hit in the side with kicks
nobody's punched me in the face yet so I
think we both were adequately concerned
about that and there was not some
ridiculous amount of money on the table
so we decided it's just not worth
pursuing how does hakara come into the
picture
because he's a possible competitor B ask
me all the time who would you fight
would you yeah people are like ah Andrea
botes would kick your ass that's a tough
one because I can't what am I going to
say I'm gonna fight a woman who I'm
larger than you know so I just have to
take the L against anytime a woman is
mentioned that's fine I'm like Owen's
still winning that one right exactly so
I've lost to both both houses Anna
Rudolph Anna kremling they're all chess
creators they're not like hypothetically
yeah I get a hypothetical fight yeah
yeah
um he's been training uh I think Andrea
has been training that's because an
event got announced this this event that
I was hypothetically going to be the
main event against Eric Rosen yeah
yeah and then you kind of like thought
like maybe let's not do this no I I knew
once I declined to fight Eric that I
would not be participating and I even
knew you know I knew who was going to be
the main event
um because I was kind of offered both of
those guys so I'm on Hamilton so is this
still going on the chessboxing event
will happen in December in Los Angeles
yeah who is the main event it's Amman
Hamilton who's also chess bra so they
have a couple of guys as part of the
challenge bro Channel and Lauren strand
Lauren strength is a international
master from England he's a
I think he's done some boxing a little
bit he's a commentator Brash guy nice
controversial guy yeah uh it's funny
because they started Lawrence put out
some videos and I went damn I should
have done this yeah I think it
but uh I mean you're right first of all
there's so many things to say one of
which is
if you're if you want to take it
seriously you know it does pull you in
like you know if you train a lot
it's going to affect the rest of your
life and then
and then there's it it changes you I
think taking Combat Sports seriously
changes you and good
and there's negative costs to it I think
because it's a whole nother thing man
it's like uh it's like doing a marathon
running or something it really pulls you
in and the other thing is the
is the head trauma like you have to take
that kind of stuff seriously especially
if you're doing sparring and all that
kind of stuff yeah
um still some of the celebrities I don't
know why but it's pretty exciting right
I don't know why it'd be fun to watch
your car like there's something I always
said if Hikaru and Magnus did a boxing
event and yeah I was the co-main event
against I don't know who that would
that'd be that'd be as Magnus said
anything about it like about doing chat
boxes uh well first of all he's gonna
commentate the Ludwig event nice which
he which he said he he kind of said oh
there's been people in the past that are
my level in chess not my his level in
chess and uh have wanted to get physical
with him I think he's talking about
Hikaru it's it's I don't think anybody
else is that'd be that'd be a good one
man that'd be a good one I think Magnus
what do you think wins that one I think
Magnus is in better physical shape he's
also a little bit bigger I think than
Hikaru longer reach I think he carves a
dog though I think I think he'll I don't
think he's gonna he's gonna get out of
there like I I don't think he's gonna
quit in in the ring I would think Hikaru
just goes nuts in the beginning and
Burns himself out so if matters can
survive that
I feel like a car would just go crazy
and then just get exhausted would not be
able to Pace himself correctly maybe
chasing that first round knockout yeah
yeah just swing like crazy honestly I
just love to see that which is like the
effect of physical exertion on the on
the game I think it's I'm sure they're
strong enough to
yes but I think we definitely
underestimate the effect of being
punched maybe bleeding out of your nose
or something like that it's it's no joke
I can't
I can't say I'm anticipating the first
day I actually do some sparring and get
seriously hit because
I know it's not going to feel good even
now I take a hard jab to the stomach or
the ribs and I'm just like man this is
this is rough I mean I
I had to do three minutes on heavy bag
and when I finished
my I had I had been like slacking on my
form because my arms were tired and I
hit with my fingers instead of my
Knuckles and my hands are like you can
see the the red skin like completely
pink meaty skin under I didn't realize
when I was hitting and only today it's
the pain is unbearable so I can't
imagine head this must be no I mean it
gets I mean it's a different thing I
mean of course your skin gets tougher
everything gets tougher so it gets used
to it I had the head is a weird one
because it's not going to send you those
kinds of signals you're not going to get
this the skin type of signals
the brain is a weird thing because it
doesn't hurt yeah
it just does the damage and the damage
can materialize itself manifest itself
only years later yeah it's a weird one
but then we all die
is there's that Braveheart speech